okay thank you very much all of the
organizers of the program and end of
this workshop in particular so this is a
joint work with glentoran who's still at
ETH Zurich so I just recently moved from
ETH Zurich to a university of copenhagen
Brent Duran he's an algebraic geometry
at ETH and while he stays there and then
there is my former PhD student he just
finished my advisor who will in a few
weeks take up a post opposition it's dan
Freudian Patrick Hayden's group in the
physics department
so he'll be close by
what since I just moved to Copenhagen so
there are some possibilities for a PhD
and no stock if you're interested if you
know someone who might be interested
just get in touch me
okay so what's the setup well I got
three parts for for this talk I want to
tell you about the setup and maybe give
you a brief motivation the next thing is
I want to tell you about our result and
then I hope to tell you as much as
possible about our proof let's see how
far we get maybe the high-level overview
of the high level overview excellent so
what's our setup
so we got to compact connected to li
groups I'll give examples a bit later
gah
okay so this is these are compact
connected the groups
just think of any sort of unitary group
you have in mind anyway that will do for
this talk I'm not an expert on League
group theory so I will try to stick to
the unitary group
all of us so there is a we're going to
take you know I'm going to have some
group homomorphism from this small group
you know that's my little group age into
the big group G right I'm going to fix
it sorry jective no not necessarily just
a group homomorphism why you did you
slower than stinky psychologically
smaller right
you'll see in the examples that it kind
of looks smaller
and
and then we want to look at something
that's known as the branching problem
that we have been discussing a great
length I have to be slightly pedantic
about the notation so i hope i do this
so i take a representation of g with
highest weight lambda so that is the
so-called highest weight again examples
will come in a minute I'm not going to
that's the highest weight lambda and I
like to write lambda is in G hat you
know that's sort of the set of highest
weights labeling this it's very natural
way to label the irreducible
representations of G like that and I'm
going to take that representation which
is a gr8 representation and reduce it to
H but I'd when I write in a down arrow
like this I mean via this group of a
morphism and that then will decompose
into a sum of irreducible
representations of the group H again now
labeled by some highest weight mu which
is now a highest weight of off of course
H right and that may come with some
multiplicity so we have this
multiplicity space here which is indexed
by lambda and mu but I'll try to keep
track of F as well for the moment ok
because it all depends on how this thing
is embedded and now you know that we've
seen this many times but for the people
who haven't seen it as many times we are
very sloppy here instead of writing the
vector space with this dimension people
destroyed
No
you know m lambda F mu
good ok let's go to some examples
some results
okay example number one is G is the
unitary group in dimension D and H is
its maximal toes so sometimes denoted
sorry yeah by TG and this is just you
won you won you won
d times and now if I take an element
from that group right that will be you
know u 1 u 2 out to you d these it will
just be phases right e to the I Phi 1
etc and the homomorphism I would like a
look at is just the embedding as the set
of diagonal matrices
the one up to you d and then zeros on
the off diagonals
that's my F okay for this example
now what are the highest weights or
we've seen the highest weight for
unitary group a lot already they're
given by the set of integers that are
non increasing
and for the purpose of this talk I'll
just restrict that they're also positive
so we look at the point 0 meal
representation and I will use the
following notation so I will if I sum
them up that will give n and this is d
so we can nicely represent this in a
so-called young diagram which you've
seen as well and here is an example if d
is equal to three then this diagram here
and would correspond to the diagram for
31 and if the dimension would be higher
than there would be additional zeros
here and if I draw it like that it's a
you know this is the number of boxes in
the first row is lambda 1 that's for
number of boxes in the second row and so
on
and i'm going to use peters notation
that lambda d n which is means lambda
has at most D rose and exactly n boxes
these are the highest waits for this so
this is the way you may think about it
and here the highest weights actually
are for each of these you once we have a
new I which is actually from Z but we're
going to take it from the positive
numbers positive integers again and then
I could assemble all these in one vector
and this is mu 1 2 mu D but you can see
that the one case is a special case of
this case just with a diagram with one
rule
okay so in this case the branching
problem is well known and the result are
this will cost car numbers this face is
at costco numbers and because we're
going to use them later i'm going to
call them k okay it's not in the chronic
coefficient it's a costco number a and
they are given by the number of and this
you remember maybe from a boot camp from
christians talk by the number of semi
standard young table 2 below
of shape lambda and content mu
this means that if i take my example
from before then i could for instance
have the following one if i take as
content to 33 then i can see for
instance here I could have this diagram
or I can put the gas like that
and then I get two possible so the
Kostka coefficient in this case too
let's go to the next example we're going
to do a lot of examples I think maybe
it's maybe it's useful after all the
next example is you d plus d
yeah why is the news not are pretty
tutors so why are the news arbitrary
heel because I just have a direct sum
here I just have you one hand of any any
weight but this is just a weight not why
are they positive because I choose them
to be positive more you're early i'm
just looking at the positive one yeah
fine cursive certainly goes you're
lactose a partition you're only good
positive and just a polynomial
representation i'm looking at i'm sorry
i would like to do that otherwise you
know anyway i think other speakers have
done the same
I think it's still easier to think about
you d then s UD if I do this with su di
could headache Nora so here I have two
unitary matrices right to d by d
matrices and i'm going to send them like
that and
okay very good that this gives me also a
coefficient can I get you the show fans
how many people know what the branching
confession is you don't have to say to
show your head how many do you know what
it is
okay good this is also the little
Richardson coefficient and swim to
see what if I'm too basic this is also a
little bit of Tristan coefficient it's
nice actually to sort of do this
exercise and show that it's equivalent
to maybe all the other definitions
you've seen
ok
and and the leadville richardson
coefficient can also be seen as a number
of hives and again I think they're you
know a lot of experts in the audience
that no know much more about it than I
do and I also don't have to really tell
you why it's important we've already
seen in the previous torque how it may
impact GCT or I was just enter in itself
I don't know who told me that but
they're sort of like binomial numbers i
was told just like some other object
that appears in all sorts of different
branches of mathematics and it would be
nice to to understand it better and also
maybe one thing that's relevant here is
that we've seen this in caitlin's talk
the the little religious and
coefficients are extremely well
understood and they have a lot of
properties a lot of things have been
proven about them and a lot of the
conjectures in GCT for The Chronicle
coefficient i believe i just kind of
like let's let's see maybe it's the same
as for the for the liberalism
coefficient it may have the same
properties so i think this gives a lot
of motivation for what goes on in the
GCT conjectures or at least in the ones
that play a role in The Chronicle
coefficient
so the next example is u of D times D
and I'm gonna in going to flick UD d in
there by taking this pair of matrices
and by doing this tensor product
all of this this you may also think of
just as you know having you 11 here and
then you know take the first entry and
then you'll be here and then you you do
you weigh 12 you be to a you be into to
you be yes action and I'm also not
hiding much so I have here two diagrams
neway and you be both with maximum d
rows and n boxes you see that here the
degree is preserved so here have n which
is of d square and then I get a
coefficient here which I write is G up a
lambda mu a mu B and this is the kinetic
coefficient you can show that this is
the same using shriveled reality as the
normal tensor product decomposition of
the symmetric group go fishing
now I first came across this thing
because I tried to solve a problem in
quantum information theory and then sort
of thought I had solved the problem
because I thought everyone's known
everything was known about it and that
wasn't the case so now I'm here trying
to figure out what what what is going on
with this quantity efficient together
with you guys and of course we know it's
important in GCT we've seen this all
along I prefer and this is my example 3
hey if you want maybe I put it I still
managed to put below I would I prefer a
different version of The Chronicle
coefficient it makes things a little bit
easier namely I want to make it more
symmetric so I want to actually consider
you d cubed and then injecting three
triple factors
just in a natural way right here you get
you a tensor ub10 so you see and then i
would like to restrict to the diagram
lambda which is just one row with n
boxes and then you can show that the
court the corresponding coefficient that
you get right there basically the one
roll coefficient with mu a mu B mu see
that is actually just exactly the same
as the thing as if you put me up there
at least if yeah yeah for the Rollings
with the number of parts and will not
there's a fourth example okay this is
one of the one of the motivations
there is a fourth example I've briefly
like to mention listen eat my time
namely the bluff ism but let this also
fits into this picture
um
then Lee you take a matrix from here and
you send it via an irreducible
representation with highest weight new
to some matrix on that space and then
you look at a highest weight of off say
degree n and then you look for the
coefficients that appear so that it's
the same as like taking the lambda you
know off the group G and then looking at
through this representation right of the
group a that thing is acting and then as
an H representation that thing
decomposes and the coefficient here I
will denote by lambda and I'll fix you
know this map f here is fixed remember F
is fixed I'm not going to write new for
the new moon but because this F here was
specified by the sea reduce
representation you I just put new here
and that gives me my decomposition so
the Platinum also fits into this picture
but remember that this new is fixed in
my talk right so this F is like a fixed
and while in the of course we know
they're important for GCT let me just
mention that there are classes and
coefficients are also important or to
understand the properties of of
indistinguishable particles for instance
fermions bosons and generalizations of
the pauli principle so there is some
relation and there is an exercise we'd
like to do that we've already seen it in
a little bit bigger let's talk maybe
that case one is a special case of
example 1 is a special case of example 2
is a special case of example 3 is a
special case of example for that's sort
of a kind of nice exercise to kind of
get get going on so let me tell you
something about complexity what we know
about them now we want to compute them
all right but I understand what's known
about them so first of all what's the
input
the input is in one case a diagram and I
put now d4 sort of the dimension of the
big group I think always of a big group
in a small group capital d for the
dimension of the big group and let us
give n boxes and the muse you know mu
again it's a partition and in the
examples you've seen I'll gloss over
this a little bit you know mu was like
one petition or maybe it was several
petitions
now what is the input size what's the
size of the input well the input is
presented to me as a sequence of
integers each of which I can encode in a
bit string and if I assume that the
total number is n then also the maximum
number for each of them will be n and
therefore the input size will be d
numbers times logarithm of n to encode
their length plus and then maybe order d
of d of log n for for encoding them you
so that's the input size then i can ask
myself what about what's the complexity
of
yes for for the moment I will just yes
for a moment that's okay but but for the
actual kind of result it's so I just for
this exposition i think is so it's not
so fix this that fixes f right that we
did before and you have lambda mu and
the task is to compute and then we have
a few problems that we would like to
compute let me give you this table I
think it's nice so first of all of
course the costco numbers what's known
about the costco numbers well we got the
costco numbers we got the little
richardson we've got the kronecker and
we got the plat ism and i think because
of time constraints we talked about the
plat ism so we can either ask let's
compute this or we can ask let's decide
if this thing is non zero or we can ask
a simple question fix f where f is fixed
and then compute this
that's not gonna change epsilon part of
the input f is just fixed computer so
what's known the costco numbers are have
been shown to be sharply hard by Nava
youngin and this implies you know that
all of them including the class ism I'll
show up your heart because they're
special cases for each other then the
kronecker has been shown to be in gap p
and x bogus and admire so it's in gap p
actually we're not going to talk about
this i don't know and the little richard
soon we actually know that's in sharp P
because of I guess this there any
results that will imply that and the
costco number i don't know who first
showed that this is in sharpie that you
can count this but maybe little wood or
something
now I think that's known you you see
this is a hard problem computing it's
right it's a counting problem maybe
Kronecker is even harder than the others
deciding on zero ness is significantly
easier and here this is shown to be NP
this is a result due to knutson town
saturation conjecture plus malmal a you
observe that this sort of works in that
setting and of course that implies that
the costco numbers are in pee and then
mama lays conjecture right he
conjectures this is the conjecture that
also the the corner isn't pee first time
he was not long before
I'm sure yes I mean maybe little would
also did it in rice is high rises
theorem very good Gail watch it here
implies that so we're just going to put
it independently MP rather work with it
again it's about the existence of 01
matrices with peace pipe marking with
you exact same time is worth nothing
okay guys let's do it so this is also
known to be in FP so you can compute
this when you fix if you can compute you
can come I just learned that that I
should use fp4 for functions that I want
to compute in polynomial time rather
than decision problems because P only
contains decision problems so these are
functions that can compute in polynomial
time this is due to crochet i believe
last letter this is fix F F's fixed but
yeah it's it is the omen worth resume
and in this in the chronicle problem it
would be it would be the Rollings okay
fixed number for a number of rows to be
okay thousand whatever this year is also
Cauchy and I think the Louisville and
Meg Alistair
so today i want to show to you well
these don't state that these two things
are also in NFP and a number of other
problems and this when i hope you
understand the statement so all the vibe
in Elaine's the rule-based hectic City
look half is fixed f is a fixed
homomorphism from here to here this
means the number of number of rows and
the kronecker is fixed okay for all
three petitions number is fixed or in
the pleasant the the inner classism is
fixed so the number of rows for the for
lambda and mu are fixed well AGA easily
didn't let me say when I say F is fix
agency are fixed yeah so f comes with it
with F comes with groups you know yeah
but in our kind of feels the one thing
about the chronic is just means bounded
Rowling's about a number of parts in the
petition oh that was because we're gonna
do it today I'm sorry about this
okay so today well today
was it today sorry ok
um well
for set up from before you know remember
f fix and the set up from from over
there with H and G in the abstract and
in a general sense you take lambda in G
hat and you think of lambda is being
presented as a in terms of its highest
weight in terms of its fundamental
weight as a linear combination of the
fundamental ways same for same from you
you is also presented in terms of its
fundamental weights and then the input
length is it's just if you if you just
assume you know let's put all of these
smaller than you know all of the bi and
ni smaller than n then the input length
it's just in this problem it's just log
in order log n after we precise me and
then our little theorem says that n
lambda F mu can be computed then Polly
Ann poly log in except so you can either
go fishin on the roads etc anticipating
binary ray yes yeah oh yes is specified
in binary your fixed number of these
binaries
and then of course the equality for the
kronecker is exactly that you know fix T
and then you're given these three
partitions
the distance of n
then G mu
can be computed
in poly log n steps
similar thing holds for the place isn't
so I have a few remarks of course if i
can compute the kronecker with bounded
depth exactly then i can also decide
positivity for it for fixed number of
rows sorry so in some sense i mean it's
um very weak sense you know this sort of
settles modulus conjectures for the for
the case of bounded world lines now in
fact this is parametric it's strongly
polynomial x as parametric in lambda mu
but i wouldn't have time to say
something about it and they are very
exciting improvements off of and into
better analysis of other things by by
panova and park very recently in
particular they can improve the deciding
on zero pneus they can prove this to
linear time unfortunately without
telling us what the what the coefficient
is in front of that but nevertheless
it's very nice where you can you do
allow you to allow colony nonzero nice
for the contour of rose to grow but very
very slowly I don't know yeah it grows
like it's things like L you have to in
pinellas paper park went over papers
very precise I think it goes like power
dimension cubed maybe
but for cheesy kids long vaca versus
with Ronnie gotten generators of the
seminary and they're checking you've
been checking on 0 NS or checking or
computing maybe let's take it later
because otherwise I won't even be able
to tell you what the sketch of the proof
is let me also tell you that this is
fast in practice so we did implement
this for D equals 3 you can do like
before if you use normal methods you can
do maybe a hundred boxes but then you
really have fast hardware for this you
can easily loot 10 to the 8 boxes maybe
even maybe even more so so it's very
easy to and there is this website so if
you want to download the code would play
with it Misha adviser he programmed this
and he has this website leet speak dork
you can also go to my home page there's
a link to that website where you can you
can see all the information about it in
some examples serve beans and get some
geeky thing I don't know so um
you go to my home page there's a link to
it
I think Google will correct it if you
missed I please speak
come eat
okay proof how much time to wrap it ah
very good
so the proof put the proceeds in three
steps okay we get started here on the
right I'm going to put our big group G
then below it we're going to put the
little group h and remember we got this
F here GX on you know and irreducible
representation with highest weight
lambda that we want to decompose
according to this F right that's what
we're going to do so here's our
procedure so we're going to first
understand how what the weights look
like what the weight multiplicities look
like off this off the spec group
remember TG these are this these are
just these are just the diagonal
matrices
how about in ng right fast cheese you
know kind of like the unitary group it's
the maximal tours and then
4h we can also choose such a maximal
toes and a few sort of liquid person and
then you make really sure that we have
to make sure that this sets I inside
here ok we're going to choose th so that
it's a subset of of TG I will always
thought this was an obvious but
I also think about the think about the
chronic at full moment right you got the
diagonal matrices on d cubed and then
you're just going to inject like
diagonal matrices d by d diagonal
matrices this again gives you diagonal
matrix so it's just a very natural thing
these are the diagonal matrices for for
the small group products like of the
diagonal matrices and here you have the
diagonal matrices for the big room okay
so this is going to be step one then
we're going to be we're going to go you
know we want to solve that problem so
we're going to go around that diagram
like this we could do from G we're going
to reduce we can understand this
branching problem namely of course right
EG is of course a subgroup of G so I
have also a branching problem I'm here
to here this is a sub google that have a
branching problem from here to here and
then I somehow have to understand how i
get back from having understood this to
understanding the multiplicities here
these are the three steps
are there any questions to that or not
better strategy
yes um
but you know what
you know what this is right this was our
first example these were the costco
numbers so the multiplicities here so if
I decompose VG lambda into
representations of ttg then this is the
same as direct sum over and now excuse
me I will label them by beta now okay
before we label them by mu but now we
label the mo betta and then i have a
costco numbers here
and then V TG beta now TG is a other
diagonal matrices this is an abelian
group the Arabs of this diagonal
matrices are of course one-dimensional
and this costco number we know and the
costco number remember that was the
number of ways of putting Sammy standard
yanked a blow with a certain content we
haven't got it on the board anymore but
what i can do is i can write the k in
the following way and that's important i
can write it as a so-called partition
function so i can write this as kappa o
said ok that's a cuppa so i can write it
as the number of points in the following
polytope i can take que ir it's a set of
variables integers of non-negative
integers and then i can say well imagine
right this this what does what this
means this is the number of this is the
number of eyes in in row are ok so we're
going to put the number of eyes and row
are all right but if I got wait beta
right Peter was beta 1 up to beta D then
the number of ones have to some have to
sum up to beta so if I sum up over all
the roles
so we just we don't see any title okay
this is equal to beta I and then oh
sorry
kappa and then also if i sum over the if
i sum over the number of over over over
the same row right i need to get the
number of ones in the first row plus the
number of tools in the first row and so
on that adds up to the number of boxes
in the first row so if i sum up over all
these things here i get lambda mu what
is this glam de are
ok so this year is a so-called partition
function and it can be evaluated in
polynomial time [ __ ] yeah the other
column sorry the bacta column that would
strictly increasing the high food
things okay it's not price is always
going quite always obvious PTZ time but
there are ways to fill a young cowboy
yeah with a certain content and the
content is given by the contents given
by beta
and I just count the number of but it
will be some manner he has to be some
extent there's a semi stay still it may
just says the kitchen is conditions
content there's a little more thing
right implied that all the ones are in
the first row yeah so I put so my
notation is the following I'm going to
look at like row are ok that's going to
be Rho R and that's going to be and I'm
going to look at the number of number of
ones in that's what you said Oh joining
okay with it but it's a polytope I think
that you just had any quality right now
problem sorry I forgot something
okay hmm well you're right it's the same
thing you said before Cal riser that you
want to take extra matrices with your
arms i'm scared i remember in beta hey
if you do that yeah you're right i mean
i have to have the ordering constraints
right so so they go up in each row i
have done i forgot the column
constraints again so the column
constraints the column constraints are
that I guess the number of oh yeah
here's some column constraints okay is
there any qualities i'm going to put
some slack variables to make them
equalities yeah it seems like the
dominance yes okay I apologize
okay upshot is it's hmm it's the number
of it's the number of Kappa and this set
D and then there is some map that takes
this vector kappa and should spit out
beta and lambda okay well anyway so
ready illuminate your number call
kingdom world points and polytopes and
then taking finite differences that's
right yes this here is constant I
mentioned there's T Square here this is
constant dimension well let's let's see
what I do so I'm counting I'm counting
points in fine dementia polytope that's
right i can do that fast with Bobby
knock and okay so what next step is yes
well it's just that projection here
really from these things to these and
then you have to you know I have to put
these ordering constraints in but we
don't do that now okay the next step is
that we we got to understand we have to
understand this decomposition now we
want to know and we want to know what we
really want to count is the number of of
poly top 12 count this multiplicity
function so what we really want to
understand is VG lambda going due to th
now but that i do in two steps I first
do v
I first do V G lambda I'm going to go to
to to TG and then I'm going to go to th
right and I'm going to see well the
first thing I already did before so this
gives me the costco number i know from
before and it gives me this
this TG one-dimensional module and now I
have to reduce this year to th right I
have to understand to which these pts he
reviews which one this is this is
one-dimensional if i reduce the action
it will say one dimensional but i'll get
a different one and one can compute that
and what you find is that
yeah what'd you find this we're going to
kind of abbreviate you a little bit what
you what you're finding is that actually
you can write it again as like the the
gamma that you'll obtain here so this
year will be isomorphic to some vth
gamma and the gamma fulfills again a
linear relation with some fixed a that
you have to apply to PETA yeah yeah is
an injured right a is a matrix is a
matrix i applied to beta i get gamma ok
and now if I sort of if I continue that
if I continue that argument then what I
have I have a sum over gamma right with
v th gamma and then here i have a sum
over all the betas such that a beta is
equal to gamma and then i have the
costco coefficient
note that this is not not yet a
partition function because they're
exponentially many beat us here i sum
over right but i can write it as one
partition function because i can just
write this as i can just write this as
the number of points we can one can
easily show that that you can write this
as a number of points y and beta such
that Phi of Y is lambda and beta and
this a of beta is equal to gamma
it's basically you take your partition
function from before you put the beta in
as variable and you put that restriction
on that restriction that a times Peter
gives you back gamma and then you got
again like a fixed partition function
one single partition function and and
that thing you can evaluate fast very
nice and then we got the third third
step third step is of course the
question and that's how do i recover
from the multiplicity function how do i
recover the multiplicities but you know
how to go from here to here that's
that's vile character formula to go from
here to the functions and basically the
opposite is just an inversion of oz
character formula I like to call this
the derivative principle but the lemma
is the following
so if I'm given some representation some
representation v of in our case now H
then I can look at you know it's not
irreducible necessarily i can look at
the at the multiplicities you know what
is this here is the multiplicity
function this is the the number of times
a certain and Arab mu occurs in V this
is the highest weight multiplicity and I
can relate it to the
to what I call so I call this now k
lower by mu I would want it to denote
that here by so I want to so I have this
weight right i managed to compute this
weight multiplicity function with Barbie
knock now what I want to get back that
that thing back and there is a really
nice formula namely you can you can just
take you can just take partial
derivatives wait finite differences
right because everything is finite but
so what is the alpha so what is alpha
alpha are in li language these are the
positive roots in our kind of
down-to-earth world these are just
vectors with a one at a position and
then a minus one at a position later
and what is this d alpha doing so d
alpha applied onto onto my multiplicity
function is just it's just taking the
derivative right so it's just doing kv u
plus alpha minus k mu right that's a
finite difference I don't bother about
dividing by anything that's a fine a
difference that's what this d alpha does
and of course if you now apply this you
know the number of roots here that is
that is that is a constant it's a
constant because the dimensions
everything was fixed on morphism is
fixed so there's only a finite number of
such objects I need to do and with a
finite number of of these differences
right I can recover the multiplicity
function from the weight multiplicity
function I only need to evaluate bar
enoch finite number of times and then
then I get my multiplicity
um that's how it works I'd love to give
you an idea I think I'm out of time so
that's the idea so there's these two
small add-ons that I would have had one
is to tell you the proof of this or at
least an idea of the proof you can ask
me later in a break and the second one
is that actually this whole formula here
it's very much simply even if you do
that if you do the corn occur so it's
even simpler if you do the corner here
just a very simple kind of formula thank
you for your attention
oh well the the partition function so
this this this basically poliquin occurs
right I started with a symmetric space
right and in the symmetric space the
weights all come with like multiplicity
1 so I start with like this Kostka
function which is just very super simple
it's just you know 1 0 0 so then I take
the projection of that so my my my K
gamma you know gamma a gamma be gamma C
is actually just the number of points
and then i sum over this year are you
know this is sort of Z to the D cubed R
I'd sort of like T cubed I mean the you
know it's like these are all here and
they're like d variables in each and
then you have the projections and the
projections suggest that you take that
do take two variables and you sum them
together and it gives you the it gives
you if you sum the second two variables
together it gives you the projection so
you get gamma a and then cyclic right if
I take the
if I take the first one and the last one
that I get gamma B and if i take the
first one and the second one and i sum
over I JK then I get gamma C k and that
is the partition function and then
define a difference is these are just
ready to find out differences just
correspond to adding a boxing and and
removing a box you just add a box and
remove a box from these from this thing
right and is it true in the to roll
thing you get eight terms so I'd you got
to add and remove a box at a remove box
at a remove box all the eight
possibilities will you know if you with
like plus and minus signs so this also
immediately shows you that it's in Cappy
because you can just collapse them and
then and then you have like these
petition functions how many but what I
can go to serve for sweet sweet works
that hard of 34 doesn't work anymore
well maybe one works hard he can make
question maybe the software bank and
malton he uses varbanov Andy programs
1400 you I uses the Barbie knock library
I think yeah and you can also do the
parametric version I don't know it is
like I guess him know you really have to
ask him
because
you go
look
and
Linda power
well i mean i don't know i mean you have
to ask the practitioners but i think you
on in these libraries you can't do more
than 100 boxes if you push it now boxes
yay this is you can do 700 thousand
boxes here if you like how many rows
houses in 210 you can do like three rows
right you can hit three rows but you can
easily do 10 to the egg boxes you know
10 to the 8 boxes like there's this
example I mean if you go to misha its
homepage he's got this example where you
where he computes the number four i
think seven hundred thousand four
hundred thousand and whatever 100,000
maybe I know don't ask me something that
that's a partition right first rolling
700,000 second roll length 400,000 third
full-length hundred thousand and he gets
the answer here
particular contribution because for fix
roll length right four four four three
two military road yeah I can't go more
than three words yes syp complete take
it you have no hope right you have no
hope of going for arbitrary roll length
of course you may hope that instead of
like three votes you could to four rows
of five so the fact that the problem is
he is a cap it was it was known that
it's very hard to prepare algo de comer
to logical point of view with existing
religious
see I don't know in my in my opinion it
I mean I think it was not clear that you
have the same easy boats they insist on
every software for little later yeah I
don't think any of them gives you more
than hundred boxes but i don't think
anyone them gives you more than hundred
boxes know when they can do more than
three rows but i don't think they can do
100 boxes okay they came to more than
500 boxes socially qualify state me by
the experts here they can't do more than
500 boxes I can only do three rows but I
can do a million boxes there okay yeah
there is known but
ok